those are some funky parallel hello
everybody my name is markiplier and
welcome back to three scary games we're
gonna be starting off with Sakura no
gaku the Japanese inspired or Japanese
made horror game that's really really
good so let's see it this is a horror
game set I believe in a Japanese school
where a lot of horror games happen but
we'll see what this one has in store for
us now
I like clock
yandere simulator sound but what is also
probably a very common japanese school
sound I like this interest it kind of
establishes the mood and the theme
really well oh don't drift off to sleep
don't do it
that's no don't drift off that's how
they all oh no that's how this always
starts then you're in loss in a horrible
dream world oh no she did oh no oh no
horrible dream world here I come oh my
god
what the hell what this control so weird
I can't turn so oh oh there we go
suddenly Oh
well I hate this oh I'm sorry I meant to
wait oh I got a job just didn't even
give her a chance
whoa okay crouch yeah okay but just
blanc my head straight onto that thing
excuse you know creepy whispering what
I'm about to process what might be a
mannequin one might be a corpse okay
looks Lahti big duty to you getting real
low on it
what who inspect okay oh that's way
closer than I wanted to be but I didn't
do nothing I didn't stab you I didn't I
didn't do that and where'd you all come
from all right okay if you're okay can I
take that knife that seems like it might
be good for self-defense at some point
at some juncture
yeah I'm a brave boy but mom tells me
that's bad I got a bad feeling about
this guy's
I just think maybe there's problem
happening here in the school and I'm
about to face head-on ready for me to
surrender laying on the line to fight a
jump-scare
I knew hey did you just like did you
just like sprint straight through a wall
hey it could feel like right in front of
me and I wouldn't know because I'm not
facing that direction okay I'll go I'll
go in here well let's do a nude painting
of whatever the monster is okay yo okay
I didn't know that's bad hey why that's
me um that's not me I want to be very
clear I got nothing to say about this is
where weird circumstance okay all right
we're just gonna let that be
[ __ ] this [ __ ] this [ __ ]
he's a blood are those different offense
[Music]
like that
hi okay I don't know what happened I
don't know what I saw
I'm gonna pretend I saw nothing off like
this okay I guess one clacks adorable
perspective here if someone is Stimpy
stepping behind me and isn't telling me
I'm going to be very pissed off oh
that's my shadow
oh that was smart I one point a very
smart game development because it
reminded me of the ability to Crouch by
having to crouch under that to probably
avoid detection there by crouching
berries not what I wanted to be hello
[Music]
wait wait wait wait a minute this is
gonna this is who's just gonna show that
to me and not this is good okay I guess
we're gonna walk towards that hi hello
fellow student I'm juice oh okay you're
fine then what are you throwing away you
need a flower okay so I gotta get a flat
work
I think someone shout out a flower in
the bathroom back there let me this is
not the
I've got a flower the flower my flower
you're welcome and then you fade away
into nothingness I'm not sure if that's
a good thing did I save you
those are some funky parallel why are
you doing this to me oh I wasn't ready
for that
I wasn't ready at all okay all right I
was just I was minding my own business
oh [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] Wow what I can't
I can only run so fast no one for me oh
my god no no no no no no no but I was I
was right there but I was right there oh
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] I can't how do I go
jump I'm a hippity-hop foot a hip butter
oh I mean
okay if I'm piecing this together right
what I just saw was that was like her
dad or something or someone she knew
probably or dead she had hung herself
but she lived so she was in some weird
dream world but then the monster was her
dad so maybe she was abused too which is
even sadder if you really think about it
you don't even have to really think
about that just oh my god or maybe it
was something about LeMond ster
following her out of the deep I don't
know either way it's bad news either way
it's bad news but that was great
oh my god Kenny Amira syndrome Coast
Doreen max Zack well done for as simple
as it was the game the concepts that you
were putting forward their goddamn good
all of them all of them everybody even
at the bottom god damn good that just
had this sense of dread Zac this sense
of dread Nathan Yi Lin like this putri
this sense of dread
Wow like legitimately was terrified
there it was so good is so short but so
good the setting like the theme of it
the mood was set with that intro
cinematic the game was tight it had
super nuance like game game mechanic
like teaching it was work well done I
think I see something down there now
that was awesome
it was awesome oh it was awesome all
right moving on but that was awesome
love that everyone play that it's in the
description everyone play that that's
good
terrifying welcome to room 303 yes I
pronounce room that way but that's not
the point here this is a game a horror
game that's supposed to be about a room
that's numbered 303 do you guys
understand how much I know about this
game before going into it because it's a
tremendous amount so I don't know what
to expect
obviously like most of these games oh
okay oh okay was that you was that a
demon in my brain oh that old demon okay
fix this you got it buddy all right let
me just put all your blood back in you
patch that hole up with these shards of
glass that are on the inside of the
apartment did you jump into my hotel
room and just die on my floor or were we
in this okay if I'm looking at this
logically let's just look around the
room first couch overturned TV dead
basically but a sweet guitar right here
oh that's nice okay and then a demon in
my head telling me to fix this alright I
don't there's a lot of things that I
don't understand either you were
standing in this window and oh wow
that's actually real that's not just a
remade animation that's cool
so someone are you Larry bill earnest
Larry bill earnest here was standing
standing proudly in this window just
loving life living life looking out at
that and then a sniper with a very good
knife thrower well I'm gonna go a sniper
shot him crash the window in to the
apartment he spun dramatically oh and
then fell and died and this isn't my
fault this is just random happenstance
from a sniper a random random sniper
okay all right
to leave and call the police
it's our foe it's our phone here but I
can use I could turn out the lights
close my eyes take a nap play guitar Oh
done fixed it fixed it good all done
also I'm swaying like I'm drunk this
game is like slightly nauseating fix it
fix it pretty good okay so that guy's
me-me-me guy is in a panic oh hey how's
it going there it's 3:15 apparently okay
it's important that's what time it is
now
so okay all right fix that fix that fix
that
wait that's clean clean ox
okay that's bleach so I can mop up some
blood if I'm ready to do that okay I
don't know what this is trying to do
what's it trying to say I don't really
know 100% if you could just spell it out
for me if you could not be obscure with
fix it and you know and all better to
like nothing
yeah oh what up dude what's with this
ghost here can I clean up the blood now
or do I drag him Oh
maybe I should like cover it up with the
sheet okay you know what I'm gonna
answer it it's it's fine all right hey
neighbor
why are you doing there oh hi oh wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait hey buddy
hey what are you alright well if you're
just gonna watch Larry even even Stephen
okay goodbye
see I gotta go sorry good little close
close turn the light out okay hey buddy
Oh Oh go away be gone thought Shh I'll
spray your eyes out let me get that
stain out for you hey you shouldn't walk
around with ketchup on your shirt okay
anyway it's good with the door open here
we go Shh stag bad dog bad
hello what did we do what do you mean
what did we do Oh
okay all right okay what do we do what
do we do what do we do what the games
ending was I mean what do you mean by
end game huh
the end of the game and game oh what the
[ __ ] hell
okay oh there we go oh it was made for a
theme of one room oh okay that's so
weird
wait what wait so reset you mean I have
to live that loop what's the room under
a movie like room 1303 where he couldn't
leave was that kind of like the theme of
it like you have to oh man maybe uh
Annie just exits well that was room 303
not bad I'm a little confused but not
bad moving on this is in the GAR a
horror game of some barky doggy Julia
your daughter is kidnapped in an
apartment building la Hacienda come if
you want to save her but I warn you if
you show up with someone else or you
talk to the police I will kill her and I
see you in that place in an hour
oh that's not good what was my
daughter's name again I've forgotten our
Julie Julia I think Julia Julia it's too
dark I should find a way to turn on the
lights
good old la Hacienda I don't remember
what la Hacienda means by deed sure
lives up to the name
whether that is or is not correct it
seems like one of the classic horror
games like give me an empty apart
building apart building apartment
building and send me snoring
okay yeah like most apartment buildings
they just toss bed frames into the
stairwells hello someone huffing paint
in there or there's beer cans not sure
which well I haven't found anything to
power yet but I bet I'm gonna find a job
scare or two hello Julie Julie okay
thank you thank you for that okay when
did the creepy music kick up now and
supposed to happen okay I came a few
hours ago but your wife was not at home
so I entered by force I took your medals
I will not return them to you until you
pay me my money if this is a recent note
who's living here who has a wife here
who's raising a family here oh so these
do open this building is alive I doubt
that but okay it's like a Silent Hill
house is that what you're saying
I didn't think these are working before
but apparently they are working okay
honey I went to repair the hole in the
wall of the guy from apartment number
one he hides the hole with a bookcase
that falls so easily that man is so
weird he stole three metals from a
neighbor and kept them in his bedroom
honey I want to move I'm sick of this
place is full of crazy people
why only people like that live in this
building why do you live in this
building
why do you live here don't live here
alright so someone has a bookshelf that
falls easily this one no I'll spend in
one of the other rooms down here I mean
this one didn't open yeah so it must be
this one over here one of the ones that
I passed by on the way in I probably
should have found a way to get powerup
but hey Here I am wandering on my own I
said no bookshelf here this one no it's
a mattress
alright so must be out towards the
beginning of this area and if it's not
that I'm stupid Locka did
so this just doesn't open I just get to
see the beer cans and nothing else
all right well seal oh I hate the way
those open those open badly please is
this what kind of place is this
where's an interior decorator when you
need one this place is in trash
I meant to say a travesty but then it
came out a load of trash okay is this
the bookshelf that falls away so easily
it is sorry my brain needed some physics
to process what the hell I can't I
stumbled across okay okay all right so
he stood on the sink like my pet
goldfish is down there somewhere and
Dover headfirst okay that's the only
reasonable explanation here and there's
no other explanation
oh okay three metals why do I need three
metals why would I need three metals in
what universe would I need three medals
only a good thing I got that information
upstairs first this place will eat you
yeah apparently the toilets too oopsie
whoopsies right why would people live
here why why would anybody leave there's
there has to be like inspections at some
point somebody has to ins old sugar the
rabbit I don't want to sugar the rabbit
was toy belongs to my daughter she must
be here okay whatever you say bro
whatever you say in case it's the power
Kerch uncles oh well that would have
been much easier well that would have
been much better okay do I have nothing
else to say about sugars rabbit being
here why do I have three medals okay all
right I'll just wander I'll just keep
wandering dudes and dudettes I'll just
keep wandering around this weird place
oh no oh [ __ ] he made it down he was a
dreamer he was a dreamer and he made it
down finally I always knew he could do
it I always believed in him I was
believed and now he's just like he
always dreamed just like he always
dreamed I just find it rather hilarious
enough silliness back to the seriousness
so there must have been a reason that I
needed three medals right so I have to
like give somebody three medals or it
gives something three medals or takes
three medals somewhere so the guy who
got the medals Solon for them is was
[Music]
whoa Samuel I'm tired of your offenses
and humiliations I love you and I always
will but can't be with you anymore
I know these metals make you feel
horrible but I don't understand why you
got so upset when I booted them in the
metals holder you were fourth place you
were second place you were third place
never the first you were never the best
it's something you were not even a good
spin well I can see why he got upset
because it feels like you're just kind
of mocking him all right way fourth
second third so that's specific that's
there for a reason
fourth apply fourth second third apply
did I do it
I did something I did something
everybody oh oh oh oh oh
[Music]
okay that's just gonna happen now my
wife left me this morning and my tennis
career is over my neighbor's taking my
medals but it does not matter
he's second third and fourth place just
remind me I'm mediocre and useless I am
now I'm sure that nobody's better than
me I'm the most talented I'm the best
who's this guy me huh figures
egotistical as me no way
okay why why why [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
[Music]
well that scared the poop iana me a my
dad is the game done is that it or is
there more that's scared - OH
wake up wake up it will come back it
wants is to torture you you have to
hurry you only have a few minutes before
returns find this silver amulet before
time runs out when you find it
that thing will not come for you anymore
why silver why can't I be gold first
place I first place me best I'm the best
I'm the best at everything and
everything you versus I'm the best why
are you you for seems familiar are you
my daughter are you my daughter there's
no time for that
dad find the silver amulet before time
runs out it has to be in one of the
apartments okay alright if you say so
oh [ __ ] oh oh [ __ ] alright well uh
oh [ __ ] okay silver metal one of the
apartments I'm gonna die well I don't
like a ticking clock definitely don't
like that Skoosh okay that's not scooshy
no more mister friend man isn't there
there's one thing this game as
graphically it's kind of fun like
mechanically it's a little wonky but the
music and the ambiance they they did
that good that jump-scare was good that
junker got me
that's dumb scare gummy like goodly
building is live and I'm aware of that
and where I don't know what to do about
it okay you don't need to do that it's
gonna be on the floor that is silver
ambulance CD oh wow it's Guns N Roses
guess it would be up here wouldn't it
silver ambulant I mean did it silver and
mule it could be the second place thing
no I can't take those okay well [ __ ] I
don't know what I don't know what it
looks like I don't know what it looks
like I don't know what about I don't
know how much was it no is it just gonna
be sitting on something or he's gonna
die horribly silver amulet Guns and
Roses [ __ ] dicks I'm so dead is that it
No
[ __ ] ass Undead Oh poopy Oh pooping my
pants oh I don't like that I don't like
oh I don't like that oh I don't like
that no I don't like that I'm dead I'm
dead
oh I don't like that oh I don't like
that but I like it Wow
okay whatever you're doing oh oh [ __ ] oh
it's doing the thing again [ __ ] cat [ __ ]
can i Huff some glue [ __ ] that's gonna
get me all right don't just do it just
does kill me
[Music]
don't don't don't monster
come on oh just do it already eat me
like you eat the toilet oh just do it
I'll just do it already guess you're not
gonna do it you're gonna do it I know
you're gonna do it let's do it whoa hey
whoa whoa hi all right I don't know
where the Frick this thing would be all
right let's try again let's look in the
rooms very carefully we're looking for a
silver amulet I don't know what that
would be but let's start from the back
and work our way forward this apartment
anything here silver amulet I can't open
this any more
so that's not there it's not in the
toilet it's not there it's not an occur
tonneau kay I hate the audio not here
it's not down here in these apartments
you almost find it you almost find it
what does that mean there's nothing here
there's nothing it's nothing it's not
the silver thing here it's nothing where
the hell is it ah I don't know man it's
not here where was it silver amulet
well here I go again all right no I'm
gonna do something stupid I'm just gonna
turn around and I'm gonna back that ass
up into the monster and whenever it gets
me I won't know I won't know who knows
where is it oh where is it oh there's a
bad idea there's the stupidest thing
I've ever done well here ladida leader
here we go I don't know what knocking uh
oh my god Oh Oh
oh this is a silver amulet now what that
was it hmm all right okay all right I
could have sworn that I saw that before
or look there before maybe it changes
maybe it's all random I have no idea but
the timer still going is there another
one oh okay uh I guess I just hi how are
you my oh so you want your daughter she
belongs to me now you're so miserable
she deserves a better mom oh I was a mom
oh you'll have to kill me to take her
away from me but I warn you I'm not easy
to kill oh well I'm not easy to get to
I'm not easy I'm not easy period if you
know what I mean okay I can't see
anything now if we're gonna be fighting
in the dark is this why you're not easy
to kill oh I'm sorry I'm sorry wait I'm
sorry
my god oh my god okay worried about it
oh what a God so that was in Dakar not
bad I really liked the atmosphere it put
together I really liked the atmosphere
but once again the game mechanic itself
gets really like it's almost like the
game mechanic gets put on the back
burner
towards the atmosphere and the horror
aspect of it and it's like it could be
ooh it could be so much more if the game
was actually fun to play a lot of horror
games fall into this trap they create a
gate a great setting the setting is
great the atmosphere is good it really
draws you in you know the story kind of
is like there but it's not it's not
perfect but like the gameplay itself
horror games cannot just be walk from A
to B collect a thing put it in B slot
that can't be all horror games are at
its core it has to be a game game
physically it has to be a game and it
has to have mechanics that come tie into
the game and it has to do that this was
decent
it had a great scare it got me good but
as a game needs a little bit more there
and I'm not I'm hoping I'm not being
overly critical about it but it's just
like I feel like there could have been
some more stuff here I go into an
apartment I find my daughter okay I get
that what do I need to do why am I here
what am i solving other than finding
this mystical metal that protects me
makes sense so either way that's IndyCar
so that was three scary games some
pretty good stuff there a few flaws on
some of them that kept it from being
something memorable but Sakura no gaku
was amazing so thank you everybody so
much for watching you can find these
games in the description below and let
me know what you thought down in the
comments as well thank you everybody so
much for watching if you've got other
games that you want me to play in the
future write in the comments thanks
again and as always I will see you
but I
[Music]